first tonight our country is facing a
crisis of confidence most people have
not connected the dots we're going to
try to tonight the most dire threat to
free and fair elections in the history
of the United States it is now coming
from within we'll explain it all by
coordinating with the DNC and big Tech
top brass at our own FBI have been
putting their thumbs on the scales of
our elections now for years the last two
presidential elections in particular and
the mob and the meteor are totally and
completely complicit through outright
censorship through lying through
disinformation not vetting candidates
they all deliberately work hand in hand
to help elect Democrats all across the
country but thanks to several new
investigations a handful of reporters
and a guy by the name of Elon Musk
that's right the billionaire the full
extent of this corruption is now
beginning to come to light and tonight
we're going to walk you through this
step by step it may seem complex but
it's all also actually pretty simple
we'll begin tonight with Elon Musk after
Twitter's bombshell document dump on
Friday that's centered around Twitter's
2020 Pro Biden censorship campaign well
musk said that all of this during an
open discussion on Saturday at a round
table over the weekend take a listen
really if if Twitter is doing one
's bidding
for an election shutting down dispensing
voices
on a pivotal election
that is the very definition of lecture
interference and what the hell else
would you of course it's like yes
um you know that frankly Twitter was
acting like an arm of the Democratic
National Committee it was absurd
well that would be election interference
and an arm of the democratic party but
it gets worse according to musk Twitter
was not acting alone many in the media
mob were not being truthful to you the
American people shocker take a look
well I think those people should be
looking in the mirror and wondering why
they were deceptive why did they deceive
the American public and and instead of
trying to redirect blame to Matthew to
be accepting some responsibility
themselves for not being truthful to the
American public
now there's no doubt that many so-called
journalists are now downplaying musk
Revelations because they were in fact
complicit in twit in Twitter's
censorship efforts in 2020 short shortly
after Twitter blocked any and all
sharing of the hunter Biden laptop
report from the New York Post NPR
proudly announced that it would not be
covering Hunter's laptop from hell
because quote we don't want to waste our
time on stories that are not really
stories and we don't want to waste the
listeners and readers time on stories
that are just pure distractions now
countless other quote journalists they
falsely refer to the story as Russian
disinformation or hack material now this
gave cover to Twitter which was blocking
the report without any legitimate reason
according to newly released internal
documents Twitter blocked the hunter
Biden's Story the laptop story on the
basis that it could be hacked material
and their hack material policy but that
policy reportedly requires that law
enforcement find evidence of a hack that
never happened because the laptop was
not hacked it was Hunter's laptop even
Twitter itself admitted that the Hacked
excuse would not hold up according to
one former employee quote hacking was
the excuse but within a few hours pretty
much everyone realized that that wasn't
going to hold but no one had the guts to
reverse it and yet Twitter utilized an
emergency tool only used for the removal
of child pornography to block users from
sharing the report even over private
messages now Twitter officials also
eagerly worked with the Biden campaign
to remove other objectional
objectionable posts this internal
document from October 2020 features five
links that the Biden team wanted removed
three hours later a Twitter employee
responded handled these now keep in mind
journalists Matt taibi reviewed these
internal documents and to be clear Matt
in no way acting on behalf of the
Republicans but this Scandal is not
about conservative or liberal ideology
it's a story about what a systemic
political bias it's a story about
censorship it's a story about propaganda
and misinformation that is now being
institutionalized in big tech companies
that are seriously harming our country
and the next level of this is our own
FBI's involvement and that makes it far
worse and I'll get into this in a second
and it goes well beyond the hunter Biden
laptop Scandal take a look
all accounts that were requested to have
things taken down by the DNC and by the
Biden campaign even ones that have
nothing to do with the hunter Biden
laptop if they will also be released uh
intended to release uh all the files
um so it's not like anything that's
hidden this is like whatever Saucy files
or
um Your Truth and Reconciliation like
Nelson Mandela would say you know it's
it's if you want reconciliation there
must be truth so
um
that's that's the intention intent here
is to just make it make it clear what
was happening and provide transparency
about the past
now additional documents are forthcoming
and we can expect more of the same and
according to taibi almost all of Twitter
censorship favorite the Democratic party
now that's because in part almost
everyone that worked at Twitter was a
hardcore liberal Democrat in 2020 over
98 of political donations from Twitter
employees they went to Democrats now
this year that number was up to 99.73
percent that's nearly 100 percent and
that brings us to one former Twitter
employee in particular his name you've
heard it before James Baker you might
recall in 2020 he was working as
Twitter's Deputy general counsel and at
the time Baker advised Twitter staff
that it was quote reasonable to assume
that the hunter Biden story is the
product of hacked material and urged
quote caution but a few years earlier
back in 2016 while he was with the FBI
and he was the top legal advisor for the
FBI and then Baker through all caution
to the win reportedly disseminated
Hillary Clinton's dirty disinformation
Russian dossier to the entire media this
is the same dirty dossier put together
by ex-foreign spy Christopher Steele on
behalf of the DNC and the Clinton
campaign it could not be corroborated or
verified even after the FBI offered
steel one million dollars in early
October of 2016 to back up anything
approve or corroborate anything in his
salacious claims now that's because the
dossier was for always made up it was a
farce unverified and unverifiable it was
filled to the brim with actual Russian
disinformation or bar talk as they
called it but that did not stop the FBI
from using the dossier on four separate
fisa warrants to gain access to the
Trump campaign their transition team and
the Trump White House even after Steele
couldn't corroborate it and collect his
million dollars and then after his main
source danchenko said it was false and
said it was bar talk they still lied to
the fisa courts they said it was
something it was not they said it was
verified they signed their name to it
what do you think would happen to any of
you if you lied to a judge in a court of
law think about this the FBI committed
fisa fraud they did it knowingly with a
fake document to spy on a candidate and
then a president but in 2020 they
seemingly made no effort to investigate
a laptop that they had had for 11 long
months that in fact not only implicated
Hunter Biden but now the president then
candidate Joe Biden and a variety of
serious pay-to-play schemes in fact on
April 28 2021 when the FBI raided Rudy
giuliani's residence for whatever reason
they didn't take his copy of the hunter
Biden hard drive even though he offered
it to them they said they didn't want it
that's because they already had
possession of the laptop for nearly a
year before the election and it was
handed over by the computer repair guy
John Paul Mack Isaac it was handed over
by the computer repair guy so he gave it
to them he will join us by the way in a
few moments the FBI had plenty of time
to corroborate in that 11-month period
of time the authenticity of Hunter's
laptop the information on the hard drive
the crimes that are obviously committed
on that laptop and they did nothing
instead they heavily suggested the
laptop Scandal was part of a Russian
disinformation campaign now here's where
the FBI's involvement most people have
not put this together gets very serious
now we know and now we have learned that
the FBI as reported by foxnews.com met
with Twitter and other big tech
companies weekly in the weeks leading up
to the 2020 presidential election in
fact we're now learning that the FBI met
with Twitter and other big tech
companies and according to Twitter's
former head of sites Integrity many of
these meetings involve warnings about
quote hack and leak operations by state
actors with some involving Hunter Biden
likely in October one FBI agent recently
testified that the bureau used these
weekly meetings to Lobby social media
platforms to change their terms of
service and then censor content now
clearly the upper echelon of the FBI
were putting their fingers on the scale
they did it in 2016. they did it again
in 2020 and we now know that Hunter's
laptop from hell is very real they had
all of Hunter's emails all of his videos
doing drugs and hanging out with women
of the evening shall we call them and
how Joe Biden was directly implicated
and involved in his son's Shady
international business deals take a look
and now to another key figure in this
impeachment story Joe Biden's son Hunter
this morning his business deals during
his father's time as Vice President are
drawing new scrutiny Joe Biden himself
uh two of his family members his son
Hunter Biden of course uh and his
brother James Biden have received
millions of dollars from politically
connected Chinese interests and I
remember looking at Jim Biden and saying
how are you guys getting away with this
like aren't you concerned and he
certainly looked at me and he laughed a
little bit and said plausible
deniability
a 2013 trip to China getting new
attention this morning not for what Joe
Biden did but for who he brought with
him his son Hunter joining the then vice
president on the official visit to
Beijing of course we have one email back
on May 20 2017 uh where uh somebody's
writing this is actually James gillier
writing to Tony boblinski don't mention
Joe being involved it's only when you
are face to face I know you know that
but they are paranoid unknown to the
press back then Hunter Biden was forming
a Chinese private Equity Fund planning
to raise money including from Chinese
investors years later Hunter Biden
acknowledged that during the trip he met
with the Chinese Banker which his
spokesperson describes as a social visit
not a business one the real conspiracy
here was the Democrats big Tech big
media keeping this story from the
American people just days before the
most important election we have election
for President of the United States
election for who's going to be the
commander-in-chief and you have a family
involved with all kinds of foreign
business interests and we don't get to
hear that story
still no consequences for Hunter no
investigation into Joe no early morning
raids no process crimes connecting
anyone in Biden's orbit at all and just
like there was no search warrant or
charges or Consequences for Hillary
Clinton when she mishandled top secret
classified information no prosecutor we
were told would prosecute forgive me if
I'm a little cynical and roll my eyes
when they raided Mar-A-Lago looking for
top secret classified information or
accused Donald Trump of collusion no
prosecutors ever prosecute all of these
things uh because what he's a Republican
and he's not a Democrat do we have a
two-tiered system of justice uh it looks
like we do the FBI the DNC the big Tech
the media mob must all be held
accountable before our wonderful
American Republic is ruined forever hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else